are you guys doing good good this is I
like the backdrop in this room yeah yes
let me start by saying how much I love
the show just love this show I am
constantly amazed at how much you guys
do on screen and get away with like I'm
just blown away about the subject matter
have you ever had any resistance this
Netflix ever say to you no we have had a
very very very few moments when Netflix
was a little like ooh this I don't know
about this we they were fine with us
having oral sex with the severed head of
Garrison Keillor this was season one
this was before he got at it for me to
something but it's season two the
interesting thing that both of these
Jenni's character of Missy and Jessie's
character Jessie go to a Korean spa and
see all the different types of women's
bodies including Missy and Jessie's body
they show that they are comfortable
eventually being in this basement okay
with their bodies they disrobe and that
was that's been a very interesting level
again Netflix was incredibly good
partners in doing it but I think Jen
flack it and and the writer of the
episode Kelly galuska were very
interested in talking about that these
girls could be naked and that it doesn't
just because a girl is naked it doesn't
make it a sexual thing and trying to
find that line of how you can have that
moment and but also make it about what's
happening in that scene and not about
this bigger issue was it was an
interesting thing to navigate and and
Netflix was incredible partners in doing
so but we we tried to try to find that
line that's actually specifically wanted
to talk about with episode 2 of season 2
I've never seen that in in any show
trying to deal with this subject matter
and showing like cartoon characters like
I was just very impressed with what you
pulled off and I was just curious what
everyone thought I mean I think there's
there are certainly good reasons for why
some depictions of especially like young
woman's body
are prohibited but I also think that
it's really important to try your best
to change the dialogue or around our
bodies and it's scary to be kind of like
I would say up like a pioneer in that
imagery because there are like people
who are unwell may look at those images
and be like you know and those are bad
people but in general changing the
conversation and using the images in
different ways I think it's really kind
of fundamental to like tearing down an
old way of looking at women Louis I
think it's important also for young
women to see you know I I remember being
that age and 12 and 13 going through
puberty and your body's changing and it
was very uncomfortable but there are
times when you're naked and you're
looking at your own body and like you're
processing your feelings about it and
you are not sexualizing yourself in that
moment and I think it is about how can
you see a young woman's POV of herself I
think like that where she is the subject
of her of her story and her feelings and
like still like you're saying kind of
protected I think and there you can't
get to her story unless you allow the
freedom I think of like seeing how that
girl sees herself and that starts with
being like don't be predators even
basically like it doesn't start with the
like for me I remember just recently
like thinking about this episode and
being like I wish that somebody had been
clear with me when I was young because I
was so curious and continue to be very
curious about my own body that my body
is personal in private but it's not
secret and it's really weird when you're
a kid and you're like oh I just like
want to see what my butthole looks like
or something and you feel like it's a
secret like you're doing something wrong
just by exploring and taking a look
looked at my own what's going on back
there it's fine
I always overlooked at mind the other
week we'll keep your secret write them
on a scroll I get the wailing girly
it's why the show is so funny yes I know
what I mean um how much did you know
about the full arc of the 20 episodes
going in and how much was it sort of
being figured out as it was going I
think we go more season by season than
we do like 20 episodes in I think like
season one we had clear ideas about
where we wanted to start and finish like
that we Andrew we thought and we but but
we leave as much as possible for
discovery that like Andrew and Missy as
soon as we started writing and starting
to voice the show that there might be a
really fun relationship there that we
didn't know whether it would be good or
bad or how it would go in the end in
season 2 Andrew my partner came in with
the idea of saying like I really think
we should talk about Shane and I he's
like I have an idea for like a shame
monster and I was like maybe it's a
shame wizard because he wizard feels
more like the key Shane can cast spells
on you and that Jesse's character would
be going parents would be going through
divorce and we would know that Jesse
would be going through acting out but we
try to leave as much as possible for
that it sounds so cheesy but to like let
the characters tell us what they think
should be happening as well as talking
to our incredible cast of actors to say
to us like hey I think this is kind of
what Missy's going through her Jesse's
going through or maybe you know we try
to get as much feedback from them as
possible what do you think would support
three of you what do you guys think
would surprise people to learn about the
making of the big mouth if anything yeah
I can talk well you guys think yeah
torch our chart I'm just
I mean it's all I think the one thing is
like we we do do it sometimes in pieces
you know like we want to try to be all
in the same room but for as coherent as
it isn't as much as like I feel like the
community of children and the characters
are so are so close to each other like
we could you have to record in pieces
well crazy schedules yes not surprising
I think it's kind of surprised well I
think when you watch the final cut ever
feels that way no when you I think it's
there's a looseness to we were you know
wanting to keep a looses to the feeling
of one kid that everyone's talking to
each other and sometimes we get people
in the room together as much as much as
we can but it doesn't always happen I
guess uh-oh one interesting thing that
people should know about the show is
that I've actually never ejaculated so I
that might be I don't know if that's
interesting to the decider audience
boring but also shocking you know what I
mean for my stuff just dripping in semen
one thing that is been surprising to me
doing it because I was thinking about
time was a singing and a how like this
likes having to sing is it does take me
back I feel your fame wizard feelings
there are so many moments doing this
show in the booth where I feel like I'm
not to talk about my incredible acting
but more just for me the human that I
find myself really feeling adolescent
feelings while I'm doing it in ways alia
that are very interesting upsetting
fascinating yeah I mean well yeah I mean
both of your performances are like the
show I think is you know we want to make
the funniest show we can but I think
because we're talking about puberty to
do it proper service it's like it has to
be as emotionally driven as possible and
I think both of both Jesse and Jenny
give like such heartfelt emotionally
driven performances that it it it's like
it's it's crazy because you think of
voice acting is like everybody's just
going to messing around in the room but
it's like you have to really be acting
in there
and so I I don't know that's one of the
reasons I love the show it feels very
authentic and real thank you
you